In this final section, we're going to cover several suggestions and tips for working with
Sequencer and Sequencer workflows.
You are free to apply any of these recommendations to your own projects based on your established
pipeline.
Depending on your project setup or technical requirements, you may want to take advantage
of sublevels.
Sublevels are simply levels but nested under a persistent level.
Some advantages of using sublevels are asset organization and level segregation,
isolation of level assets based on departments.
Note, if you're using source control, each sublevel can be individually checked out and
worked on simultaneously.
For virtual production-based workflows, you can opt to segregate your content by area
of expertise or department.
Maintaining organization is crucial for efficiency on any project.
This is especially true for Sequencer workflows, where a well-structured system can prevent
wasted time and frustration.
Remember to apply organizational principles to your file and folder structure, asset
hierarchy, and overall workflow.
As previously mentioned, using subscene tracks is a great way to keep assets segregated
and facilitate concurrent work.
As each subscene track is a separate sequence, this allows multiple users to work on the
main sequence at the same time.
The example on screen has broken the main sequence into separate subscenes based on
studio departments.
Feel free to use the same or different structure based on your project or pipeline needs.
Unreal allows you to create, save, and export layouts, which can then be imported for later
use.
As you become more familiar with Sequencer, you may find that showing or hiding certain
windows will improve your workflow.
You can save a layout and load it when needed, or copy it to another location to
maintain consistency across your projects.
Here are a few common shortcuts used when working with Sequencer.
You can also change or add shortcut keybindings under Edit, Editor Preferences, and selecting
the Keyboard Shortcuts menu.
Note, you can also change or create custom keybindings for shortcuts based on your
personal preferences.
The Fortnite Whitepaper is an excellent resource guide for setting up Cinematic's
pipeline, considerations for workflow and efficiencies, as well as other helpful tips
and tricks for game development.
You can also reference the online help docs and community for additional Sequencer information.
Lastly, here are a few additional resources and links for a Sequencer-based workflow.